you
I am entered I was lucky number three
who entered Dark Knight is giving some
advice don't forget to look out for h2
guys okay except that give me this
little clock
come on Sicilian yeah that was the quick
advice watch out for h2 now I have this
Center hey I had this before I dropped
by Queen though I trap my queen I
shouldn't know what should I have done I
even know it's a trade oh it's a free
rug that's a free rook that's another
free rook right this quick resign yeah
it's back to tournament two a bunch of
two's a few uh few goose eggs there oh
oh in ahead of myself I could try for
each seven I could try for each seven
how do I set that up like this ah they
don't want to do what they don't want a
castle was that a mouse live it was a
mouse slip
I got a regroup positions opening up I'm
getting me down each - let's go this way
that's crazy though isn't it dark square
G - this pie is falling maybe that's
problem that's a big problem
Bishop takes F 2 we check with interest
they resigned they were afraid of taking
have to punt and the ff4 pun that was
bait they were they were afraid of
taking I don't know what oh I don't know
what happened there resign no I don't
want to resign that I want to double the
cube ok d 4 is a wonderful square so
wonderful I want all my pieces there I
was gonna go there anyway I'd love to
believe me let's challenge the one palm
it's in my territory
ok nothing was being done with that I'm
glad that it was a night I was trying to
move there's a it's tough - Mel slip
with the night
alright or oh I'm on the rook let's take
Queens off first let's just make sure
I'm up a free ruck
I'm up a rook let's do that no matter
what
probably this no matter what I'm this
pawn crazy bishop hair
he's passed push past puns must be
pushed flush attack the block hater
and now get one roof doing something Oh
take my bishop help me cut the King off
and get me here no matter what I mean -
he's pinned right back - Terman 12:12
and then a bunch of sixes age 7 ok
that's not really going to happen is it
oh let's kick this night away where is
he going now
he's trapped he's a dead duck isn't he
this is the the dead duck variation that
was bad that was bad you could say you
could say that was bad man I probably
just I probably just lost 50 viewers
with that car that's it I'm - who this
guy out
I even know I I probably don't even know
what I just said right there it's how
it's usually a mystery to me I'm playing
these tournaments and I'll watch back
part of it I'll think to my side I
really say that I did have to listen to
it again and sure enough it was that
ridiculous thing that I thought I said
anyhow this is a new game so he's a
vulnerable piece so let's jump in there
III is on fire he's gone
the queen is hit and he's this Knight is
ready to
do some serious damage let's jump around
here I could get the Queen's off in a
second
let's hit the Queen let's hit that clean
I want to do this little check here
let's make sure the Queen's are off
right here
Knight here not so fast
okay I have to be a little bit careful
my knight is vulnerable let's run away
and trade let's run away and trade okay
just push here my king could probably
just post up here I want a complete
development this is a wonderful home for
the bishop he's coming out with check
most likely unless that move is played
22 seconds huh oh I was in a pin rook
takes Bishop would have been played if
Bishop there yeah I don't need a castle
let's just trade that wasn't the best oh
that wasn't the best either
now let's trade is that material but
rook here mate it's me back to chairman
thirty thirty twenty nineteen twelve
okay
c4 c4 Queen c2 and look for stuff on h7
h7 is the new age two but it's not so
easy to get in when you go with the
theme kiddo
alright so we're gonna try for some bad
vinik oh no oh I have a check that was
scaring me though I'm not here to here
that was definitely scary could you tell
did you hear it in my voice right here I
could take and then this nightstand
shows the rook but I don't want to give
up my light-square bishop unnecessary
subjects if I came to maybe some
problems since this guy's around
so let's avoid any complications I'm
okay if the LightSquared bishop comes
off let's get my F pawn rollin open up
the F file let's get my bishop on a long
diagonal
alright let's just double I don't want
to I don't know if I want to take just
yet they're gonna take their something's
got to happen soon my night oh no no no
I don't want the gee file to open up
sure takes ok I'm getting the Queen at
the very least the very least the queen
is gone right oh oh ok they resided back
to chairman for Oh 42 that happened all
right
slider slider I ended up still try for
this stuff let me take that
okay get my Bishop on this diagonal
maybe even this one was decent
take this bishop first always I'm losing
some material huh oh no that was a bad
mouse slip or no what was it a bad
master
oh I just got I thought I just dropped a
piece I'm sorry
I'm sorry I got loud there let's just
watch over f7 I didn't that wasn't an on
purpose oh it's genuine fear right there
I was genuine fear I thought I mouse
slipped up I thought I don't even know
what I thought oh my goodness my
opponents trying to make me
it's over here and run if I need to run
I could run if I need to run I could run
okay I just want to open up the position
well I don't for h7 give a check and
come over here no Queens pinned okay get
those Queens off okay my opponent hang
on hang on get my king up my rope here
give some checks
okay that's very helpful oh no no no
this a one king upon a game it is Oh
that took time though time that I don't
have that took time that I don't have
sneak artist okay over here
Oh God make up my mind I couldn't make
up my mind
why Jeffers stalemate or point eight no
Stanley please whatever you do don't
steal me mate in three one two three
back to tournament 56 30 30 29 okay here
we go
it's not the first time I've played this
guy I see pawns get a lot of they get it
they get a workout for both sides let's
try something different
I'm gonna play d5 they're gonna play
their night here okay
okay didn't get this in get me kicked no
it could get to this square maybe Bishop
on the long diagonal okay this is a nice
home this way and build up at strong
center night here actually pick up the
dark square bishop and then somehow open
up this diagonal
I still think playing here is good
jumper on the rook defend here I'm
opposite the queen there's tactics maybe
I could have taken here and I should
have hmm
they're gonna take here no no they can't
I'm on the night let's go here with
check it stacked like that let's plate
the pin I really feel like taking here
pawn takes why did I open up this
position there's a really bad idea Wow
yeah let's you let's just just subject
your King to serious problems that's
what I just said oh there goes a bishop
oh oh it's crumbling it's crumbling can
I do something dangerous get my rook
involved I gonna get mated it really
feels like it's gonna be me
movemove the night huh I could sneak in
here this is actually me whoa
right matin one or the Bishop of Queen
us to just black us to make computer
moves to delay mate oh man oh man
lucky duck what was I doing with g4 how
ridiculous was that very ridiculous 72
42 42 42 less than 20 minutes remain
okay stay focused stay focused my
opponent oh they're at negative 11 they
might know they are gonna play they are
gonna play on push nope I get a temp on
the Queen if the queen is gonna
recapture okay they're gonna give up
that light square bishop no let's occupy
the center now that's where I have an
advantage two-to-one majority in the
center get all my piece is working on
pointing up their king there might be
some tactics okay definitely going for
this pinpoint now III and b2 I might
want to throw my knight here maybe
there's not even a rush with capturing
on the e3 maybe I should pile up on it
it's reinforced my Center I did it I
think I'd be quite alright if the knight
goes for that now I'm gonna take since I
was provoked and jump my knight in here
tricky Forks on f2 queenside castling
probably if my knight is kicked maybe I
could just do this actually out there is
it my move no it's my opponent's move
for a second for a second I thought it
was my move when I thought it was just
thinking King here is a mating one two
three
smothered mate my queen is not getting
trapped I have this covered by my queen
right here don't Castle if not here
please no Castle kingside oh my goodness
my queen is dead again maybe not I need
some room could this Queen go somewhere
else where she's not guarding III
I gotta take the rook there have no time
anyway back to tournament I used too
much time 90 64-56 I think my queen was
trapped again she was trapped again
let's close out of that game okay let's
go to another game that's going on it's
not pairing me up oh okay I was gonna go
to that top game slider all right
more tempos another two two two one
majority in the center and I'm looking
to kick the night away and not allow him
to post up in the center so now he has
to go to a highly inconvenient Square
I think c5 was intended I want to keep
my bishop on the diagonal for sure and
get rid of their dark red Bishop plant
my queen on h6 and my knight on d5 oh I
should have stopped that Queen here a
drop back to this square okay let's get
that night out of their trade arcs for
our bishops are they gonna really take
here it's better to keep the tension I'm
gonna take my bishop pawn push figured I
figured okay so at least I got rid of my
bad my bad bishop and it's doubled rooks
to be a little bit concerned about
dropping my b3 pawn so this isn't scheme
is not ending anytime soon my knight
needs to regroup and I'm also doing this
to get my F pawn working and it's also
helped from a helpful to my King to get
involved and not she's quite sure where
the knight is going I think he's he's uh
he's having trouble finding something
constructive to do yes
I'm not sure what I'm even doing okay
maybe I am now he wants to play here
okay is that annoying I don't even I
don't know what I'm doing I'm dancing
we're both dancing okay now I'm gonna
come over in this direction
okay you're gonna take that I want my
knight on c5 I can't move I'm having
trouble moving that's where you belong
Knight took you forever to do something
good
oh that's a free rook another free rook
three move it is tricky time burners I
only have two seconds where is the clock
where's the mate got crazy pigs why
what'd I just say I had pigs on the
seven and then the eighth I think they
didn't know what they were and I did
think we were just BOTS trying to check
each other they came down with that oh
the free bishop they were in pre-move
mode they were in pre move load that one
oh that was brilliant by me right there
what was my response if my opponent
pushed g5 that's oh that's the home I
want I'm on the bishop easy to miss I
have this square covered back to turn
three zine 130 89 80 to 70 to 72 halfway
point Dragon Fire - all right English
yeah I think I'm gonna go for this
Knight Age 3 F 4 D 5 journey can't play
this now this has to be a little
annoying or does it not really I don't
even have enough support for this jump
in here
do I could have done that directly did I
really need to move my rook I should
have moved my coin okay dark squares
let's take here and then push I don't
want to allow d4 I want my queen to
occupy this I want my queen on this
square right here okay I have enough
defense for that I'm having serious
trouble with with what with moving all
right we're gonna have a bunch of trades
here and I want even more trades get
those Queen
oh that's a free Queen that's a free
Queen there my knight wants to do what
my knight wants to get to f3 I'm on the
rook as well
alright f6 I shouldn't want my Queen
here first let's try this again King
here okay pawn push it's a mate actually
I didn't even have the g4 squared that's
what I was I thought the pawn push would
clear the way for some lateral movement
for my rook to the G file but that h5
Pound was guarding g4 I didn't really
and quite have that did I what I'm
getting a powerful powerful model smooth
Tamura
you saw that I was ready to decline that
right away my opponent is flying oh
there goes our queen almost almost goes
another clean right there
okay opposite sides castling let's open
this up and it wants to be I'm gonna
take away because I'm on the bishop I
like having that tempo and they missed
that they wouldn't resign would they
let's try to keep this closed this pawn
is annoying okay they're dropping stuff
my bishops there to defend Knight moves
there's tricky discoveries I can throw
my knight in here actually make use of
the C file pin
not now though we defended open it up
pawn takes its mate free move they would
do that King around here do not get
mated okay Knight takes Queen takes this
is coming there's that discovered check
bishops hitting the king and the rook is
hitting the queen cool block okay where
is that mean let's check
okay they resigned back determine what
170 122 109 10 about 11 minutes left
let's try let's try D for the black my
Dean or gambit something something
different
keep that pond keep that have a space
advantage now and I still have a space
advantage with my pawn on d5 Bishop d6
he's the block hater so I'd like to get
rid of him to make sure I could castle
successfully though I have this covered
something I can't be too comfortable
there's pin after g5 I think I'd
probably take but not that take but now
this is between e3 stuff here how did
how does this Bishop get out where is he
going to go and it's off for some
exchanges take the rook and then take
the knight I'll just pile up on the
knight Knight takes here I'd do this
first oh they're on my cool
I'm on their queen in the rook though oh
no no no I'm under Queen take that one
and now jump my knight in to this square
when I got an f7 or aged seven
did I just I just blundered right did I
now slip or something is that making a
move my opponent has good coordination
don't like that
I hear stop that stuff I should have
gotten a pair of Brooks off 18 seconds
that night needs to go he's got a go
there Bishop is very good as well
they've good coordination very good
coordination I need to time burn my way
to victory it's not gonna happen Rep
checking each two can't let a rook get
to g2 it's close to happening tricky
checks Oh what was I just saying oh man
what was I just saying is this savable
disabled no way
so stalemate is there any stalemates I
have a pond after move him I can't go
there stalemate
no it's me blunder I was just saying I
didn't want to get allow a piece to get
to g2
oh they got to g2 oh man anything but
allowing that I couldn't even recall
where I got a or I made a mouse slip I
think I dropped a piece there in that
middle game didn't any I'm gonna take
that cuz I'm gonna go clean side i think
i'll i let the the next guy right back
into the game
i think it's a lot closer now okay okay
get rid of the darts for a bishop and
look for me even with this month kicked
that night away actually get rid of him
he's a bad man maybe bishop here was
better this move could maybe be played
I'm gonna take care
horn and then it's a matin - where's the
mate where's the mate wait here not
quite working I'm not seeing it I need
quick wins where the quick wins I want
to get my queen here night here
okay I'm closer to it maybe having me
here mate threatened to it takes night
oh ok if I get rid of that they're back
on my queen though get rid of this night
these are these are not quick wins not
even close to being a quick win got this
night I have a time edge ok post up here
and not even sure what to do ok I'm
winning more material on both of these
guys I have this square covered but my
night
where's the moon they resigned back to
term where we at 188 180 206 minutes six
minutes imagine just imagine if we get
paired up the excitement the excitement
that single-game would bring is it gonna
happen is it gonna happen is the big
question
oh it's Knights dead it's happened
earlier didn't it some kind of a similar
thing with a g4 move oh oh boy okay
they're playing very fast
okay similar idea happening on each
seven ready to lose another piece let's
drop back I could have played here okay
here comes a big bad rook can I make one
accurate move somehow it takes your
knight here just so I don't have to give
up my queen I really don't want to play
without my queen am I getting mated oh
just try this 11 seconds why did I do
that
oh oh they didn't go after my queen that
could've had my queen and I had very
little time run okay cut the King off
okay what's the cleanest path to victory
here right here one and then two oh that
would have got crazy if my opponent kept
more pieces on the board 208 198 188 Oh
less than five minutes remain
I need a strike against h2 opponents not
gonna fall for that play this guy before
Oh going after my clean stop Knight d5
stuff open up the H file okay they can't
take with the H pond they're subjecting
their king to checks
and let's jump in here Fork threat at
the dark square Bishop Bishop pear
Bishop takes Knight is available keep
this close get my bishop right here but
not so fast
let's guard this pawn pawn push might be
decent these doubled pawns are very
strong pile up on that night of castle
it's a difficult pin to get out of I
have Knight g4 stuff as well
Bishop check queenside castle rook takes
h2 pins a lot of pins Knight takes pawn
pawn takes pins here pins here pins here
maybe that's a free night looking for me
otherwise many times I would have just
done what I would have just traded
Queens there Knight takes pawn I should
have been doing yesterday they takes
pawn coming up less than 10 seconds I
really feel like I could do that no
matter what next they're in a very tough
spot two pins King in the middle Queens
on the board dark square weaknesses to
28 to 12 to Oh 800 it's free minute
warning who's gonna get in the right
amount of game is right at the last
second that's what it's gonna come down
to unless I could sneak one of these
games and really quick really quick I
have a central vantage here are they
running home
I jumped my knight in castle open up
this and Bishop f4 should have been
playing pawn push bishop check Bishop e7
let's give it a check bishop here I push
immediately before castling I'm on the
clean now two minor pieces for the clean
so I what it's gonna be actually Queen
takes bishop I take here with check
first they're gonna resign to be very
helpful very helpful two minutes two
minutes I need to finish this game and
get one more in I think though the
Queen's dead they're gonna resign or is
the main probably take that Bishop they
resign back to chairman come I come I
come I come I come on two forty two
forty eight to twenty eight do I have an
advantage with the if it turns out to be
a tie I think I do I'll decline that
decline the Smith more oh we might have
h2 it's happened against strong players
before definitely has stopped 95 I could
also take tonight that Bishop out of
there it's happening oh it's a close to
happening if this Knight moves Knight
takes Knight and then a bunch of checks
not far off
look c8 let me give that guy up
okay that pint could probably be taken
oh this is me I got the Queen at the
very least with check with check and now
Bishop here where is the mate Bishop
takes e4 25 seconds 58 seconds left on
the game clock I should check open up
the I should plate here to try to peel
up in the D file that's me
so what I needed to 68 228 I think that
seals it yeah I'm pretty sure it seals
it right it's got to try for scholars
mate scholars mate
f7 oh the night's trapped again oh is
this gonna be me no not quite you could
run away in there calm the tournament
they resigned though they resigned
didn't register though 288 should have
been 288 if they actually resigned in
time all right
oh man g2 - man good games off all right
268 - 28 - 10209 very close battle there
for third between four people I think no
just just those two alrighty
you